Australian police just confirmed three
are dead and four injured after the 10th
16 hour siege in downtown Sydney the
victims include two hostages a 34 year
old man and a 38 year old woman and the
gunman v a 50 year old man all three
victims were pronounced dead after being
taken to the hospital and police said in
a news conference just now that 17
hostages total had been accounted for we
also found out that a police officer
suffered a non-life-threatening wound to
the face but we don't have much
information on his injury at this point
all right so walk us through this how
did the situation unfold the crisis came
to an end just hours ago after heavily
armed police stormed the Lindt chocolate
cafe where hostages were being held by a
lone gunman
rapid gunfire and explosions you're
hearing just there rang out for about 30
seconds shortly after several hostages
escaped with their hands up one person
who wasn't seen leaving the building the
suspected gunman who has been I've
identified as 50 year-old Iranian man
Haron moni's
Moniz is reportedly one of the
casualties at the scene he's a self
professed Muslim cleric with a long
criminal record according to Australian
media we found out today he was
connected to the murder of his wife and
was charged with more than 50 counts of
sexual assault prior to the hostage
situation moniece was out on bail that
what about ties to extremists here the
terrorists have officials said that this
is an act of terrorism it's an ongoing
investigation we don't know yet but he
is believed to be acting on his own he
did when he entered the cafe and took
the hostages forced some of the people
to hold an Islamic flag up in the window
it was also reported that he was asking
for an Islamic state flag and on a
website believed to be his that has
since been taken down he was also
pledging allegiance to Islamic state so
this certainly heightened fears that it
was tied to a broader terrorist attack
but at this point
officials believe it is just a lone wolf
attack